a very warm good morning good afternoon
or good evening in whichever part of the
world you are i would like to welcome
you all to the much awaited event of the
year omics research symposium
before we get started today i would like
to introduce omixlogic
to begin we must ask what is
bioinformatics
it is the development implementation and
usage of methods and software tools for
understanding biological data
bioinformatics has practical
applications in healthcare agriculture
and mitigating climate change
as this field progresses
bioinformatics poses several challenges
for both students trying to learn it and
faculty trying to teach it
in this presentation i will explain the
current challenges and limitations in
bioinformatics describe how we aim to
address these challenges with the omics
logic portal
describe bloom's taxonomy for learning
progression and how it can be used in
bioinformatics coursework
explore the omixlogic portal and how it
utilizes gnomes taxonomy in structuring
its course pipelines and projects and
finally describes several outcomes of
the omics logic portal
i'm sunali khari and i'm the omixlogic
community manager i'm responsible for
daily interaction with thousands of
users that are a part of our
bioinformatics community which is
managed by pine biot
over the several years we have had the
privilege of working with a number of
organizations developing a training
program for research oriented students
faculty and improvising bioinformatics
making this discipline accessible to
thousands of students and faculty around
the world
omix logic research based training
programs are a result of close
collaboration between buying biotech and
numerous academic institutions that have
participated in content evaluation
curriculum review and project design
so what are some of the challenges that
the field of bioinformatics is currently
facing
to begin this field is constantly
growing and developing new tech and
software to improve processing time and
power
the data sets that are analyzed are
usually very large and they take immense
amounts of computing power and memory
that many personal computers do not have
also despite being publicly available
data are also usually complex to access
and coding knowledge is usually required
to do so
similarly analysis pipelines and
programs require coding knowledge that
many biologists do not have
in a university setting students have
the opportunity to learn the
bioinformatics project
of designing and implementing a project
but do not receive practical or hands-on
experience with the full workflow
due to the faces due to the limitations
that i just mentioned
similarly faculty faces challenges with
being able to cover a diverse range of
topics if they are specialized in a
certain area of bioinformatics or if
they are unfamiliar with bioinformatics
in general for example a professor whose
research focuses on oncogene expression
might not know much about the
metagenomics of seawater
to overcome these challenges the
omixlogic portal was developed this
program aims to standardize organize and
systemize bioinformatics training in
order to make these analysis usable for
any biologist or clinician
there are some traditional problems with
the standardization of bioinformatics
coursework
which includes materials for courses
that are usually developed in-house
taught sporadically and are rarely
updated
the omixlogic portal introduces new
material that keeps up with new
technology these courses
need to be organized because the
challenge is to combine several
different topics together the flow and
transitions between subject needs to be
developed this is addressed at omics
logic through introductory material
which is being woven throughout the
courses
the last challenge we face is
systematization
how can you know that someone is stuck
and needs help or allow someone to run
forward to address this omixlogic uses
standardized modules and interactive
sessions beginning with mastering
terminology and concepts to implementing
these concepts with real data sets in a
project based approach
here is an overview of the learning
process in order to create a path of
skill development comics logic employs
the bloom's taxonomy levels of learning
this approach starts with the basics
where students recalls facts and
terminologies and are able to repeat and
memorize the material with this base the
learning builds to conceptual knowledge
being able to understand concepts and
apply information to new situations
the students will then be able to
analyze data by drawing connections and
evaluate when to use certain methods
this leads them to the highest level of
learning the ability to design and
create original work
so how do omixologic resources help
advance bioinformatics teaching
omixlogic is a portal for practical and
theoretical learning of bioinformatics
composed of courses designed to take you
through the theoretical knowledge comics
logic takes a combination of training
modules data analysis tools curated
project data sets and interactive
sessions with mentors to give a student
a clear part of the bloom's taxonomy
pyramid
no matter what the user's initial
experience with bioinformatics is comics
logic is a useful tool for gaining a
baseline knowledge of the theory behind
bioinformatics analysis of large data
sets an introduction to basic boring
languages like art and python are
beginning a data analysis project
these six courses were taken from the
core or mixed logic curriculum which is
available online
beginning with an introduction to
application of bioinformatics and an
overview of data types the student is
able to learn terminology and factual
knowledge to build upon
from there genomics translatorics
metagenomics epigenomics and data
science are introduced each course
starts with important terms and concepts
and then introduces case studies and
pipelines related to each one
this allows the students to gain the
conceptual knowledge in order to begin
their own projects
omixlogic expands upon its basic
curriculum with specialization track
projects
bioinformatics methods are best learned
in the context of real case studies
prepared by our network of mentors and
collaborators that illustrate how
various bioinformatics methods and omix
data types are used in current research
in medicine biotechnology agriculture
and even astrobiology
the projects are prepared by taking
publicly available datasets and using
them to explore and understand both the
research challenge and the analysis fact
to extract meaningful insights from
complex pharmics data
in this symposium we will hear from
speakers from different domains of life
sciences
talking about relevance of omics
integration of omix technologies
advancements in biomedical research and
also we'll hear about machine learning
view of multi-omics integration
what we will discuss today and
throughout is a result of hard work by
amazing team led by company co-founders
dr alfred dobber who comes from a
medical background has an extensive
expertise in oncology immunology and
biochemistry of information and has been
recognized internationally for his
generous support of many research
projects and initiatives that support
data science training and applications
in medicine
dr yunet brodsky is the director of
tribal bioinformatics research center at
the university of haifa and is an expert
in bioinformatics and biostatistics
he has numerous publications in
mathematics and bioinformatics and over
uh his course of his career he has
developed multiple novel algorithmic
approaches to biomedical data analysis
under his leadership the trauber
research center started collaborations
with research teams at such universities
as the university of california san
francisco institute pasture
turin university and many others where
research labs are working on
cutting-edge research projects studying
viral and bacterial infections and
designing novel drugs and vaccines to
treat and prevent infections diseases
the rest of the team includes experts in
bioinformatics computer science and
training some of our team members will
be presenting to me as well
to give students the options for
analyzing a given data set
code dependent paths or port independent
paths these data sets and associated
publications can be used in several ways
you can learn bioinformatics without any
coding at all
for that in each project we explain the
analysis pipelines on the user-friendly
tbi info platform for big data analysis
you can also learn the scripts behind
many of the steps learning to wrangle
clean visualize and analyze data in your
own analysis
finally you can hear about the projects
and their research applications in our
mental guided programs where experts
share their experience and support
research projects developed by you
here is an example of the code
independent pipeline the pipeline
builder interface on the tbi info
platform is a color coded pipeline that
helps establish a logical connection
between the technical names of data
analysis methods and the logical steps
needed to build the full pipeline
data is put in a as an input file
and then analysis can be chosen based
off on the type of research
each analysis is separated into three
columns blue for pre-processing red for
mapping and green for quantification
each time you click a button a pop-up
will contain additional information
useful for building the pipeline
the ease of the color-coded buttons
allow programs to be run without any
coding knowledge interactive outputs
allow easy visualization of the data
several demo pipelines with real data
sets are available
for students to practice the workflow
including demos on genomic variant
calling of cancer cell lines 16 as
amplicon analysis on diet and its
analysis on the microbiome and a
pipeline for examining a phytogenetic
analysis of ebola virus
to answer your curiosity about the g
biology platform we have among us
researchers for travel bioinformatics
research center who will highlight few
areas of analysis available on the
survey dr julia pano who will talk about
analysis of bulk and single cell
transcriptomics data on the t bioinfo
platform and dr elizabeth
will talk about metagenomics data on the
tip ironfor platform
after using the t bioinfo platform to
visualize the pipelines and practice
analyzing students are then able to take
their theoretical knowledge the remember
and understand levels of blooms and
apply that in a project
the apply analyze and evaluate levels of
groups then check their comprehension
with levels and batches certificates of
completion and test
similarly faculty should be able to
assign the homicide portal to their
students with an understanding that it
will give them holistic understanding
and comprehensive knowledge of
bioinformatics beginning with bytes and
molecules and onto designing their own
question based project
omixlogic employs a hybrid approach
combining learning and research to
ensure that students are building off of
the first level of knowledge taxonomy
omics logic tracks progress with
activities like pipelines coding and
literature reviews quizzes on topics key
terms and important questions and covers
a broad range of topics like biomedical
research biotechnology and agriculture
their students are able to continue
their knowledge base with a research
assessment making sure they are able to
understand methods challenges and
results as well as being able to
comprehend primary research literature
and recreate the methodology
they should also be able to ask
questions based on data exploration this
leads to the ability of to encounter
errors in their analysis apply
theoretical knowledge of why those
errors are occurring and find a solution
bioinformatics combines life science
terms with data science skills which
allows researchers to answer life
science questions with reproducible data
analysis methods
logic is proud to collaborate with many
diverse programs across the globe we
also work with over 15 000 students at
community colleges franklin j community
college
top tier universities like georgetown
university as well as 20 universities
around the world
we are pleased to have among us
researchers from our partner
universities and institutions who will
enlighten us with their talks on
different topics relevant to any student
or researcher
from knowing about technology and soft
skills uh for industry skill sets the
missing link between academia and
industry to understanding genotypic data
personalized therapies for cancer
patients and hierarchical patient models
in this presentation i explained the
current challenges and limitations in
bioinformatics
i described how we aim to address these
challenges with the omixlogic platform
we discussed bloom's taxonomy for
learning progression and how it can be
used in bioinformatics coursework
we also explore the omixologic program
and how it utilizes bloom's taxonomy in
structuring in scores
pipelines and projects
and finally described several outcomes
of the omixlogic program
want to know how to get started the
omixlogic portal is easy and free for
anyone to register with many courses
and online mental guided training
programs in the field of omics that
includes genomics transcriptomics single
cell transcriptomics metagenomics and
epigenomics
also you will find programs in the field
of bioinformatics
structural biology infectious diseases
and precision medicine
these programs are available all around
the year and you can get started with
your specialized training anytime at
your own convenience
once you have a specialized training
then you can work on an independent
research project
again under mental guidance on different
specialization tracks which includes the
analysis of data types
you learnt in the training program these
specialization tracks include oncology
infectious diseases precision medicine
neuroscience data science for biomedical
data analysis metabolic disorders space
omics agriculture and comprehensive
training on omics data analysis
throughout the year various students and
researchers joined comics research
fellowship program and work on their
research projects to either gain new
skill sets or to complete their polished
recitation or for a publication to add
to their achievements comics research
symposium will provide a stage to such
research fellows to present their
innovative research projects
also all the research projects will get
a feedback from our panel of judges
the omics logic training has been
completed by over 24 000 participants
from 187 countries in over 500 workshops
and due to this fast growth our team is
now working with local and recent
coordinators that are helping refine the
local program logistics and leverage our
online training resources adapting them
to the needs of students and researchers
around the world
as a result we have acquired
professional certification to offer our
curriculum and support research projects
using our omics logic project based
curriculum and here are some amazing
stats from an year-long training
programs that were conducted by us
the symposium is divided in three parts
where we listen to speakers from asia
first
then africa and finally the americas
so to begin with an introduction to omix
logic asia i would like to call upon
stage dr mohit mazuma
dr mohad mazundar is an experienced
viral information with multiple
publications in peer review journals he
has been developing collaborations with
universities as a mentor and project
lead for omixology training and research
fellowship
over to you dr mohammed